but all that's in the way from getting
married but to be honest there's not
gonna be much of a difference in us
getting married in reality legally
there's going to be a lot of changes but
in reality we're already living together
it's gonna be the same
yeah that's I've never had a issue with
a prenup I don't know why people get
emotional about it because if your plan
is to stay married then what does it
matter
yeah that's what I said so I follow this
lady on Instagram at take the love pill
she really breaks down femininity and
masculinity and because of women's
hypergamous nature a prenup is not
necessarily a bad thing because you get
the resources if you stay but you also
get resources if you if you try to leave
and it's actually very hard to have an
airtight prenup but as a woman you can
put things in there to advocate for
yourself your peanut doesn't just have
to be about his security it can be about
your security I can't get into details
about mine but there's things that
happen after five years ten years stuff
like that financially on my part and
people would say well if you're a woman
and you get married you're just supposed
to stay married and if you leave then
you get nothing I don't think anybody
ever plans for the death of a child and
very few people's marriages can survive
that so I mean I think we're just doing
what is sensible
well and um
if a guy loves you he's not going to
want to leave you high and dry like even
Donovan on his channel he said like if
me and Devin don't work out like I would
financially help her the rest of her
life
like like guys don't want to just leave
you like they're not these evil men that
just wanna
okay yeah I I know you're all good I
know probably having some wild people up
in her up in her apartment it's always
somebody I thought somebody knocked on
my door and it scared me but I think it
was just the storm you know when you
when you do that it looks like a horror
movie like if somebody's just about to
like come in and snitch
no it's all good
um in any case yeah if a man loves you
he does not want to leave you high and
dry you really think so like I like to
believe that my fiance is not a
sociopath but every woman has ever been
killed by one didn't know okay I'm I am
betting my money statistically speaking
that he's not a sociopath it would crush
him if he just left me and I was
homeless on the street or something you
know but that's all based out of fear
because women are coming women come to
me and they tell me that I'm taking a
risk by financially depending on my
fiance because we're not married but if
you know enough about the family courts
and calm all marriage he's assuming a
lot of risk but women don't know that
because we're sort of pedestalized
everything is sort of
um we're the ones that are we're having
our time wasted couldn't be an
impossibly wasting his time nobody
anybody thinks about that they just
think about the automatic assumption is
that men are bad or we're trying to take
advantage of us well and what could you
talk a little more about that because I
actually did not know that he assumes
Risk by having you like live there and
financially depend on him so yeah talk
more about it oh man a girl okay okay so
I'll tell you I'll tell you
um right so when you want to look at the
possibility of what can happen in the
United States you want to look at the UK
and the UK is much more woke than what
we have in the U.S
um so you can live with a man for a few
months and in some instances there have
been rulings that that constituted a
common law marriage so basically if the
man is cohabitating with his girlfriend
they break up she instead of breaking up
initiates a divorce do you see mm-hmm
and each state what they have that
indicates a common law marriage will
vary so in the state of Kansas which
shout out to the Midwest that's where I
live way too much gluten in this air so
here if you call each other husband and
wife and you're not legally married or
you didn't do a church ceremony that
constitutes common law marriage so you
actually have to be careful about the
words that you call each other how you
have your big accounts linked and for
what I get so worried about this
information ending up in the hands of a
gold digger I get so worried but I'll
just I will be transparent if you have a
man directly paying for a large bill for
you like let's say it's a car payment
maybe it's car insurance maybe it's rent
so the bill is in your name but the
payment is coming from his bank account
with his name that can be enough for a
woman to ask for a common law divorce
whether you've been together for six
months maybe you've been together for
several years so it it varies yeah so it
like people like oh my God you're taking
so much risk like yeah my eggs but I'm
27. like
I do want to have a baby as soon as
possible though so
well and it's not like you're doing
nothing like you're building a business
right now like you're getting the
opportunity to build like the business
that you want
oh yeah I'm so tired of these horror
stories like people out here really
looking at the color purple and thinking
that as everybody's relationship or ways
to excel I mean I don't know I don't
know if you know I mean I'm a little bit
more ethnic for those of you that don't
know I'm Puerto Rican but I also grew up
in a yeah my stepfather was black so I I
got the best of both cultures really so
there's just like these terrible horror
stories about what if a man takes
advantage of you nobody talks about what
happens if you're cherished like let me
tell you this so I just started this
femininity Journey because I just want
I'm very much a try it out see if it
helps you kind of girl and I tried it
out because I wanted to be Becky
housewife I'm not going to front I
wanted that and so I had to do research
and I tried it out for two weeks and I
was getting a lot of responses from him
positive feedback so positive feedback
gives you that positive reinforcement so
I just kind of kept doing it but he
started opening doors for me all the
time every time
all the time the doors are getting open
left and right he's always making sure I
have water baby are you thirsty stuff
like that so you know all these
nightmare stories just tell me you
picked the wrong dude without telling me
you picked the wrong well it makes it it
makes you look bad because you're the
one who chose him but and and here's the
thing they don't talk about like men are
so willing to help you like my brothers
I could talk like on and on about how
how many times they've just like helped
me with random situations in my life
that's why I could never hate that
because my brothers are like literally
like when covet first happened I was
supposed to run a marathon and it got
canceled and my older brother Austin I
was in I'd moved to Milwaukee and didn't
know anyone right he he has all his
friends run with me and he organizes
like the whole Trail so I can like run
it the whole and it was just so nice I
didn't even ask him to it's just like
stuff like that like men are so willing
to help you if you're you know nice to
them and a pleasant person to be around
yeah yeah it's true like learning how to
work with men and just be grateful for
their assistance will do wonders for you
professionally as well it's not just for
you know keeping your man happy and
things like that although that's what
works for me and I look I get it like
not every woman wants to be the kind of
housewife that I want to be I understand
that maybe they want to work maybe they
want to have a career that's fulfilling
Outlook I'm just here to help women who
want to get married and stay married I
look at traditionalism as insurance but
in regards to men just being helpful for
you
I I would say that a lot of my
professors is predominantly male and I'm
establishing better working
relationships with them all the time
just because I do say that I am grateful
for masculinity and it's interesting
because the more I talk to them about
inner gender Dynamics They Don't Really
they don't really disagree with me they
pretty much agree that women like
resources not one of these masculine
professors because maybe like masculine
in the closet or something I don't know
they're all ripped but yeah it's it's a
good thing to try out and see if it
works for you as a woman actually I'm
curious if you agree with this I I say
it's not necessarily about the money
okay like if a guy won the lottery if
he's broke wins the lottery